christoph was geht denn mein name ist
toll und ich habe eine frage an nicht
und zwar lege mich interessiert extrem
wie du deine füße kriegst weil ich muss
echt zu geben diesen ziemlich gut und
mein fall ist es ein licht auf studiert
auch du schon so ein paar die sind
verrückt hast so ungefähr weiß okay das
ist jetzt nächstes oder so schon ein
paar leipzig und so die schon dein kopf
selbst zahlen oder willst du wirklich
jetzt weiß machen dass alles was du
sagst ist 100 prozentig ist als von ding
jetzt egal ob tatsächlich geplant ist
oder nicht geplant ich will es trotzdem
richtigkeit ich mal wissen weil das echt
krank wenn du es einfach so aus kriegs-
weil
du nicht schlecht ich nicht das war
was geht ab zwei
sehr interessante frage und ich
beantworte sie die ehrlich natürlich
hast du nach nach zehn jahren in dem du
freestyler bist auch den eselsbrücken
ganz ganz klar besser und irgendwann das
war so ein wort report war das so alt
dass dort weiß was ich schon darauf
reimt und so weil du halt alles
irgendwie schon mal benutzt hast bloß
mein trick ist halt dann immer alles
irgendwie anders dann wieder neu
zusammenzusetzen so und natürlich
kommen dann wirklich spontane sachen
damit rein soll ich meine ich mache ja
total oft habe ich über sachen die hat
wirklich gerade irgendwie spontan sind
irgendwelche räumlichkeiten und sachen
die im raum stehen und alles
aber wie gesagt natürlich habe ich als
freestyle auch mein erstes buch jeder
jeder rapper ti weismachen will dass er
das nicht benutzter der der lügt er
einfach weil du hast und man dann so
einen kraft großen wortschatz das war
dann immer wieder darauf zurückgreifen
kann es auch diese ganzen wörter
wie gesagt
cola beatboxer übrigens leute abonniert